Giancarlo I do have to ask you an
individual question I was just in Brazil
at ccxp and they showed a pretty good
Sizzle reel of the Mandalorian season
three and I saw I mean it looks insane
with action tons of mandalorians teasing
Mandalore it basically I don't know if
you've seen the sizzle but it looks
massive this season and so I have to ask
you how is season three compared to the
previous ones
um what can you what can you say about
it I just think that the show gets more
expanded and and and more visually
um uh profound with each season uh and I
think it's the vision of John Favreau
and John poloney's uh David filoni
certainly that that begins that
expansion but but it's also all of The
Artisans that they trust to collaborate
with them I was blown away by that
silver reel all of a sudden the world
just came at you uh in in a much more
intense and and it's always been
gratifying uh but in a way that allowed
you to know you know that feeling that
you have of dread or Doom or excitement
personified that's the feeling you get
because the story is is all of a sudden
being coalesced for you to understand
there are other elements elements that
you didn't know about and and so I love
the mythology that goes behind this show
is incorporated into the visuals that
seem to be filmic and I I love the fact
that you're able to see with each
episode this season you're really
turning on a new movie uh visually it's
a Sight and Sound Extravaganza that
expands you to a place that look there
we can say a lot of words about a lot of
different things just like Kaleidoscope
but I think when you watch it you have
the space
to feel emotion and connection between
character
Mandalorian you have the space to feel
the largest of this universe of this
World building and you have the space to
see where you fit in
God I wish I could be that Warrior that
hero that heroine and we see the
weakness and and the power of the the
the villainous who want for themselves
and not for the whole what I love about
this show it is about our army is about
all of us
who are starting to understand once
again it's for the people and by the
people and if we stand up and allow our
voices to be heard and understand their
strength in numbers we can then recreate
the world as it should be in peace
Harmony and creatively scientifically
and politically a way for us to
understand that there are no borders
anymore and so Mandalorian exemplifies
all of that this season is off the chain
and you're gonna love it